do you know where men go wrong with  dating profiles and what they should do  so this is really interesting is having  a dog this is something that i think we  all know but it's actually a huge  benefit to have a dog in your dating app  picture i think something like 60 is  likely to be liked if you have a dog  picture if you have a cat picture you're  actually less likely to be liked by a  woman if you're a straight guy so if  you're a straight guy looking for a  female partner having a cat is  detrimental so don't have a cat  apparently for gay men it's a little  different i think gay men actually they  have a slight preference for guys who  have cats but if you're straight guy  don't put a cat get the dog